welcome back to Las Vegas now fall
officially starts next week can you
believe it which is why it's important
to stay up to date on the watering
schedule Southern Nevada Water Authority
the sponsors of this segment tell us
more
[Music]
I'm Diana Diaz with the Southern Nevada
Water Authority and we're here at the
Springs Preserve Botanical Garden the
fall mandatory watering restrictions are
in effect which means that you can only
water on your three assigned days a week
through the end of October Sunday
watering is prohibited year-round it's
important that you change your watering
clock now to avoid costly fines that can
go up to five thousand dollars for
repeat violations also following the
mandatory seasonal watering restrictions
is taking on added significance as
federal government declared a tier 2
water shortage on the Colorado River in
August which means that the amount of
water Southern Nevada is allowed to
withdraw from Lake Mead the source of 90
percent of our water supply will be cut
further beginning next year and
currently only about half of the
community followed the watering
restriction if every property in
southern Nevada were to follow the
mandatory watering restrictions change
their watering clock each season we
could save more water than is being cut
under shortage conditions so if you
haven't changed your watering clock
change it now it's not only one of the
best ways to conserve water but it's
also the law and if you don't know your
watering days you can visit snwa.com
Landscapes require less water to thrive
as temperatures become cooler some
simple tips that you can follow to
maintain a healthy landscape this fall
include Watering your grass for a
recommended 12 minute total per assigned
watering day that's all it need and you
can run your sprinklers in three short
cycles of four minutes each set one hour
apart now if you have a drip irrigation
system run it only one to two days a
week that's all it needs and you can run
it for a longer duration depending on
the flow of your emitters there's no
need to over water your Landscapes
allowing water to flow off your property
and onto the street can result in a
costly Waterway spine and you can find
seasonal watering tips on our website at
snwa.com
saving every drop of water we can in our
community is critical especially the
water that we consume Outdoors which
accounts for 60 percent of Southern
Nevada's water use so 100 of the water
that you use Outdoors is lost forever
however nearly all water used indoors is
captured highly treated recycled and
returned to Lake Mead which extends our
water supply so it's very important to
report Water waste when you see it and
avoid waterways remove useless grass and
follow the mandatory watering
restrictions each season
thank you to Southern Nevada Water
Authority for sponsoring that segment
call 702-258 save or visit snwa.com for
more information Las Vegas now will be